first of all you look hot I'm just gonna
put it out there you look so cute how
did the opportunity to be on Big Brother
even come to you um you're usually
fielding offers for everybody else yeah
the phone just rang someone asked me and
I watched it first yes um asked my
children yeah and then I said this is
kind of cool cuz I'm kind of empty
nesting I still manage you know my two
younger ones personal manage and they're
surrounded by a team so I have to do as
much as I did when Lindsey was little
but I just thought it was cool I love
game shows so I just wanted to try it
out so are you nervous about being
confined in the house with celebrities I
don't think so really
yeah I've been around them forever I
think yeah yeah and I'm not a fighter
I'm kind of a lover but I I'm gonna
definitely be a little quiet in the
beginning because I want to see who
people are and what they're about you
know but I think I may know one or two
hoping little Alliance have you have you
heard any you know my friends just saw
some focus they had the paper but I was
in it
in the paper and it was real and Julie
well right of course Julie but yeah so
there may be one or two I think it is
you know after okay so you already have
your you have a plan Alliance you've got
a plan going into the I'm just gonna be
like the mom of the house okay look and
clean and just I don't I don't know
what's gonna happen
moving on how competitive are you I'm
the youngest of three older brothers so
I was kind of a jock growing up and a
dancer so competitive but not like hurt
anyone okay
what is your biggest fear is it not
being able to connect with the kids and
your family not having a cell phone yeah
I wouldn't say it's a fear I just we
have like lifelines that we can call our
publicist and things I you know my mom
just turned 95 we had a big party for
her she lives there me so I talked to
her like ten times a day she's probably
freaking out right now and my kids
I mean FaceTime all the time yeah
Lindsay was been home for a month but
she's a new by ally went for a week
vacation because she's coming back to
record and Dakota better be feeding the
dog
that's what I worry about so early most
of the people on the regular Big Brother
they go out into the world they compete
on the show and then they kind of go
back to their regular lives you have
been in the public eye for most of your
life and they and they the slides right
looking and then so what do you hope
that this opens the opportunity for like
what's next for you now you are empty
nests I'd love to do Dancing with the
Stars I don't know they have all these
different shows now the kids are amazing
yeah like my mother when we watch that
show all the time I get nervous for the
performers though you do cuz I'm a dad
like talk - yeah - so they get a little
nervous for them you would be great
though my mother's like they get hurt on
that show you're gonna get hurt what is
gonna happen if you have a major major
personality conflict with someone in the
show I'll just move to somebody else I
don't think I really will though
cuz I'm not going in on the attack
uh-huh so if that's their modus you know
their mo I'm just gonna move away from
their target last season on Celebrity
Big Brother some of the stars had such a
hard time they sent themselves home they
were like I'm out this is not for me
well I think one of the little girls was
nursing a child yeah I mean that's hard
yeah yeah and then the other one missed
his wife what a doll he was yeah could
you see yourself quitting no not a
quitter and if I get voted off I'm not
gonna like hate the person it's a game
show yeah yeah I'm a little nervous
about we're gonna have to do
yes physically you'll be fine former
dancer athlete yeah that was a while ago
if there's a high kick challenge you
have got it I don't think they're gonna
be doing that jaren boo brother we do
see show manses know you don't mix that
you know what if there's a kid big
brother you're single are you thinking
I'm sort of seeing someone
okay label not for the next 30 days well
yeah that's hard cuz I talked to him and
I said that's okay so you're not
interested in a showmance on the show no
that's what the kids do this is
celebrity do you not on this today I
think they still do yeah oh it's only
the second I know and well it won't be
me okay I can assure you being Cameron
no thanks
the food's
you can be a little tough in the house
when you lose you might have to eat the
slop you're a fancy lady how are you
gonna deal without fancy I'll eat this
look you will
I need your course select me today
you're the first celebrity I was liking
there's a one of the chefs from the
chef's shows how cool would that be hope
for us are you a cook yeah I mean I'm a
single mom of four kids I had to pad to
eat but my mom's Italian some raisins
with a great cook in the house I learned
from my mom and my grandmother you're in
luck because you I've seen some other
celebrities today and people have
already are eyeing the kitchen so I
think this is gonna be good for you yeah
I feel like that are probably clean I
mean I do it at home what this I'm
saying do you feel like you need to be
normal like I'm home do you think you
will be the momager of the Big Brother
house in a nice what that term it's a
little no I'm not I'm a jerk yeah
absolutely
I don't know how to be anything right
else yeah to people that I don't know so
what is your strategy to win I just want
to get to learn to know people yeah
individually and take it from there what
do you think people will learn about you
that they might not know that we're
normal I'm normal I'm not like this
crazy mean person
yeah I don't know they'll have to tell
me after I guess what are you gonna do
with the $250,000 that you win
let's go go Tamika knows right and go -
can we go to the beach let's do it
I would it is so pretty there there's
for now well have you been yeah of
course and like the same crew Buena Mary
but it's like Ron that that yeah my that
I executive priest living Lohan so they
were like kids on the show living at my
house now they're like they're like the
heads of the show it's so cool
it was like going home to see my other
kids they're like Deena it was fun to be
on your show but we're very happy to be
you know they could I'm so proud of them
all it's a made it great they're doing a
great for NAS I mean she's just amazing
they're just on it and they're American
kids they brought to Greece so I know
that's cool so they're like Greece I
know and it's so which makes it even
more
it's amazing gonna fun when we were
doing the press for it Lindsey was
adamant too many outlets that she you
know she's in Dubai now she's in Europe
doing these clubs she really is not she
was also doing sick note in London the
series on Netflix got it no but that I
didn't know that she so she but she's
pretty been open that she's like I'm not
into the American paparazzi like I'm not
into like giving my life over to people
so how does she comes here to work and
family and I'm back and forth like to
Dubai as well you are my son was over
there doing real estate ally just went
for a week like we're always it's a kind
of a long fight but it's really it's
great there you love it and Dubai you're
going to now be on a show where they
follow you 24/7 with cameras how does
she feel about that she's okay she
packed my suitcase for me she gave me a
list of things no sushi like momager
yeah we did yeah and her list was
pretend she got all this makeup and the
house or to share with everyone she way
over packed I'm not allowed to sign at
all no I know like but it's better to
have more than less I guess cuz I don't
know what you know what to expect
did she give you any advice for just the
fame game in general and how much she
knows I get it yeah really just slow and
steady wins the race you know and what
are the other kids think they're cool it
my boys like do it really yeah Allen is
fine they're fine they're busy doing
their own right you know we're all in
the business so it's not a it's not a
big deal for us
just like fun for me finally I can
breathe yeah yeah you have to take out
care of and it's different when you know
I'm so much more self-confident when I'm
kind of protecting my kids in the
business when it's me it's kind of
embarrassing to say things about
yourself
but yeah it's gonna be amazing so when
you win I think what you should do is
buy a jet and then [ __ ] over to me it's
not enough money you're not 18 but yeah
you can take a chance is amazing first
class you have to fly okay take that go
ahead a nice world tour all the Lohan
clubs and then shopping and Dubai and
then come back to us and let us know how
it was okay
well I'm working a couple of shows
myself to produce so yeah Abby that's
kind of where I'm at and a book think so
fabulous yeah in between my drinking I'm
working yeah I love that you never stop
like working thinking you're like oh
I'll do this I'll do this only no miss
yeah I said to my kids if I were an
attorney you'd all be attorneys right
this is what I do and raising them you
know being a single mom like I said it's
like they just Lindsay we just all fell
into it yeah very early what did you
think of a thank you next Ariana Grande
video you must have got a kick out of
that
oh that's hilarious halogen I loved it I
was shocked I was like wait what I
thought it was the real girls when I was
watching it I was like but good hey I
plug the plug the plug is a plug yeah I
love I want there to be another one but
we have to wait until Tina gets through
with the Broadway show I know but how
cool is that
yeah I know cuz all the girls are very
into it no I saw Leo he's still young so
they could go to college or something I
know 100% my son Daisy and I was like
you're so she's gonna do it she's said
she they're all great I know I really
are okay let's make some new friends
2019 yes let's do it
Tina where are you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]